dr. Wallach thank you I'll just be very
brief seven years ago I went into a
severe debilitating depression
I have weeks in bed that I can't get out
of bed and go to work I started drinking
too much I have
I'm just any stress just sets me over
the edge and I drink and go to bed and
then I get up and I go I'm okay for a
while and now my blood pressure is
running 180 over a hundred very high so
I don't hold a rush in and the drinking
and the high blood pressure okay okay
how much you weigh a hundred and forty
pounds okay how tall are you
five seven okay so you're slim all right
give any skin issues any dry skin eczema
dermatitis or psoriasis not really maybe
a little bit dry but that's it okay do
you have any history he was a kid of
asthma bronchitis No very healthy
okay good you have children no okay she
has some low blood sugar
it was very well went down to 30 on the
fasting blood test when I was a teenager
okay and that's without medication or
supplements or anything like that it's
just way down there well they tested me
that six hours fasting tests yeah yeah
okay let's call reactive hypoglycemia do
you get you get drowsiness after meals
you ever get drowsy and watch TV get
drowsy after you meal not anymore
okay good okay here we go
okay Charmaine and here it's and she
weighs 140 pounds she got high blood
pressure and 140 pounds a little bit of
dry skin has a history of reactive
hypoglycemia the sig sauer glucose our
tests still yep today he has depression
so what are we gonna do it for her okay
for all these issues what I would do is
I would get her on a healthy brain and
her pack and I would add to that the
ultimate daily classic the synapses and
the distressed
and only environment okay okay what
would you do for the high blood pressure
well I'll do a daily out of the daily
okay okay good yeah okay so
char's exactly correct 140 pounds right
on that cusp you can start out with one
healthy brain and heart attack per month
it's about no I said for those issues I
did Oh too - okay - a healthy brain and
heart attacks - how their brain and
heart packs per month and fold over
think twice a day then two bottles a
month of the ultimate daily classic
chalice through breakfast or dinner
they'll support a healthy blood pressure
and healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries and let's see here for a brush
depression the synapses through that in
that's good
depression is actually a deficiency is a
nutritional deficiency and which you
have several of them okay
I'd urge you to get a hold of the book
Reger's ventures read the whole book but
I want you to read pages 342 344 in
Chapter 11 and you will just be amazed
at what we know about depression is
caused how to deal with it how to give
the body what it needs so your body can
eliminate depression depression is a
psychologist and psychiatrist once you
believe that this has to do with
pressure you're putting on yourself and
all these kind of things then really is
a deficiency of nutrients and of course
the brain requires all 90 essential
nutrients just like everything else so
sharp picked the right one the healthy
brain and hard pack two of those and
again the ultimate daily classic tablets
and let's see here you know it's just
let's just go with that good start and
stay away from all that stuff including
sugar yes and when you have framings
you're craving sugar and alcohol to
enjoy alcohol just looking for sugar
when you crave those things you're
driven to seek them out and use them
sugar alcohol you're really seriously
deficient in minerals which again once
you read pages 342 344 in chapter 11 of
the book rare
Cure's read the whole book you will be
just fascinated and of course the
supplement program give your body what
it needs to maximize your ability to
maintain and repair yourself including
your brain and brain biochemistry